[Music]
please welcome global managing director
Microsoft research outreach sandy Blythe
oh hello good morning good morning
coffee is served in the back there let's
go grab some of that good morning it's
really a pleasure for me and a privilege
to welcome you and to be your host for
this North American faculty summit it
was great to see so many of you at the
reception last night I hope you enjoyed
that I saw a lot of old friends and a
lot of new faces so we're really excited
to be hosting you this week at faculty
summit it's it's a really busy time of
the year for you I know that there's a
crazy number of things you could be
doing at this point in the academic year
plus some personal commitments and
opportunities so the fact that you chose
to spend a couple of days with us here
in Redmond is a real privilege and what
we do thank you for being here
faculty summit for us is literally a
year in the making each year and so it's
something that we Circle on the calendar
it's a real highlight for the folks at
MSR we're really dedicated to making
this worth your while I hope I hope it
is this is while it's the North America
version of our faculty summit we do
faculty summits all around the world
this is our 19th here in Redmond and I
hope that this is one of the best of
them in addition to about 200 academic
researchers and faculty we'll have a
number of Microsoft professionals we're
also streaming the plenary sessions live
over the web we had several hundred
registrations for the plenaries and
we'll be recording the breakout sessions
for replay and access to you later on so
if there's something that you really
wanted to see and just couldn't get to
it while you were here it'll be
available to you later on this year's
faculty summit also we have a very high
percentage of our most senior technical
leadership our technical fellows
distinguished scientists and engineers
so we're really looking forward to what
we hope will be a rich engaging dialogue
with you while this year our our summit
topic is systems and there's truly never
been a better time to be in systems
research there's so much going on that
systems research is going to be powering
with all of the devel
in the cloud the proliferation of
different devices and experiences out on
the edge all that's going on in new
hardware and software architectures have
to be rethought fundamentally new ways
of developing applications the end of
Moore's Law there's some of us going on
here we really are excited about the
topics that we'll be able to show with
you today we got to the system's focus
not only because of the focus and
importance of systems research today but
the feedback from you and your prior
attendance at faculty summit said we
wanted to kind of keep the topics narrow
so we've we've gone narrow and deep with
this topic as we did last year the
artificial intelligence we think that
that leads to rich or more engaged
conversation so each of you is closely
related to the research interests of
your colleagues we've also limited a day
attendance so there's only about 200
folks here today and again we're very
privileged that you would be willing to
join us
we'll find throughout the agenda that
we're trying to build in not only time
for deep and engaging conversations but
also some time to network that also was
feedback that we received from you in
the past I hope that you find faculty
summit to be one of those really rare
fora that you can come to that balances
an intimacy with a scholarly approach
that is rewarding and interesting and
that you get to network and meet new
colleagues as well as renew friendships
with some old colleagues here's a just a
brief view of the agenda you've got this
in the handout so we've got it's also
available to you on the web and
hopefully you will see here the kind of
balance that we're trying to achieve
between deep and broad in addition some
new things that we have based on
feedback from prior faculty summits
we're having our technical fellows and
distinguished scientists and engineers
oast something that we call one table
one topic so it's kind of a birds of a
feather session that we'll offer over
the lunch if there's a particular topic
or somebody at MSR that you're
particularly keen to spend a little bit
of extra time with and maybe talk about
some areas of interest or common
research look for those tables we'll
also do this tomorrow if you want to
sign up and host a bit of a birds of a
feather over the lunch time please do we
also are trying to help kind of folks
get to know each other because there are
a lot of new faces
both that MSR and in the academic
community they're attending today so we
have these researcher spotlights that
help you get familiar with some of the
research areas of your colleagues as
well as get to know them a little bit so
I for example learned that Laura Waller
has over a hundred cousins I thought my
family reunions were a food fight but
thank you Laura for sharing that part of
it super interesting to know that about
you faculty summit around the world
tends to be kind of a once a year event
but we are looking for opportunities to
try and maintain a dialogue in
collaboration and engagement across the
communities and so here's a few ways
that we hope that you can keep in touch
with Microsoft Research and communicate
with the researchers in MSR and we're
quite keen to have you to engage with us
this way as I say it was great to see so
many of you at the reception last night
I hope you enjoyed it
we're at the Hyatt Regency down in Lake
Washington I had two jobs for faculty
summit one of which was to arrange for
good weather I'm thinking so far we're
doing okay because that that was a
spectacular venue last night we'll be
back there for dinner tonight I'm
excited to be able to host you with the
dinner there this evening and I really
do hope you enjoyed it's a bit of a
reveal as you come in when you come
driving in it looks like it is a
construction zone it's a brand new hotel
it's beautiful I hope you enjoy it let
us know through your feedback though if
that's a great venue for you and if you
enjoyed the time there the summit is all
about fostering collaboration though
it's about a scholarly dialogue in
exchange but we want to make it a
special time as well and so we'll be
announcing some things here for the
first time we'll also be providing some
exclusives to you to say thank you for
joining us today and I actually have the
opportunity to do one of those reveals
here this morning so I'd like to talk to
you about some of the fellowship and
grant programs very briefly that we have
at MSR hopefully most of you are
familiar with our North America PhD
fellowship this is very similar to
fellowship programs that we have in
other geographies around the world it's
intended for PhD students in their third
and fourth year to full tuition plus an
annual stipend we also have what we
referred to as our dissertation grant
program in North America which is aimed
early at fourth year students trying to
get especially a diverse and
underrepresented populations over the
hump to finally get their thesis and
their their degree granted to that
though we've added two new fellowships
that we're announcing today and details
are available out in the lobby at the
booth and well will be released on the
web this morning one of its we are
calling the Ada Lovelace fellowship this
is a North American fellowship again
aimed at diverse and underrepresented
populations in computer science they
have some particular structural
challenges that historically have
touched that group and so what we're
trying to do is get a little bit earlier
in their career this is intended for a
diverse and underrepresented groups in
their second year of their ph.d program
and that scholarship runs a full three
years as well we have we're actually
bringing back an old friend it's the
faculty Fellows Program so this is
intended for faculty young and career
faculty so those who are within the
first five years of any entering the
professorial to try and again provide
some additional funding to get you
through those first few years as you're
building up your research base we're
really excited about these especially in
an environment where the funding can be
difficult to bring both our existing and
some new student and faculty programs to
you we're also bringing some experiences
so this year we'll be having our first
PhD forum which will include PhD
students from the fellowship the
dissertation grant and I think Valerie
Taylor may be here
she has an NSF funded organization
called the future leadership in the
professorial intended again to take
underrepresented groups and provide them
with experiences that allow them to
compete more effectively for tenured
positions in academia we'll be including
the flip-flop Valerie thank you good I'm
glad you're here we'll be including them
as well in collaboration with the
University of Washington which was one
of the flip alliance schools in our
first PhD summit later on this fall so
let's get started I do want to take a
moment to introduce my boss
in the head of MSR labs and MS REI Eric
orbits to say a few words so welcome
Eric good to see you
[Applause]
I want the two to just add a personal
welcome thanks for joining us it's it's
so great to see so many familiar faces
as well as so many new faces I'd love to
be to meet to meet over the next couple
of days I'm so impressed by the the new
approach to our faculty summits being
focused thematically we used to have a
much larger event that span that was
kind of representative of the wonders of
Microsoft Research which span all of
computer science across our labs and but
I think the focused events thematically
are much more productive for folks and a
little bit more more community centric
and the AI event last year was just
fabulous and I'm expecting the same from
the system's event this year leadership
and innovation in systems and networking
is just a critical area for Microsoft
Research across our labs of course it's
a critical area for Microsoft
Corporation and so it's great to see so
many of you here today see so many
people from folks from our divisions as
well as Microsoft Research as well as
people who traveled out here so I'm
looking forward to that exchange I'll
actually be around during the event I'll
be coming to dinner tonight
and I have one of these rare moments
this afternoon to present a technical
talk of some work we're doing with with
with my smaller research team on AI for
AI systems so thanks everybody and
thanks so for all your work sandy as
well very good thanks very much all
right so let's get started and with that
I want to introduce along with Dan Fay
the program chair for this year's
faculty summit
Donald Cosman Donald has joined us
actually years ago from ETH Zurich where
he was on faculty for 13 years has an
extensive and rich academic career
which he tells me is more impressive
than it even reads on paper so I'm not
gonna take you through that I am curious
though about that fun fact I wonder if
there's a cause-and-effect relationship
there he did for startups because he had
four kids or he had four kids because he
had four startups but that's very fair
of you Donald to have done that so
welcome to the stage please our program
chair
Donald Kaufman okay thank you very much
so just to start I'm done both with
children and with startups and and I
think my wife is very happy about that
probably more happy about being done
with startups than with with children
huh but anyway so I want to just pile on
what what sandy and Eric said thank you
so much for being here we know that you
have busy schedules and my children are
actually I think this very moment they
are swimming in in Lake Washington so
there are other things to do so thank
you very much for coming so why are we
here and and I think that's why I want
to start we are here in some sense all
our dreams have come true
and you probably I've heard this for the
last 20 years yeah and and everybody and
every year we keep on saying it's more
true computing the age of computing is
here and but it's but I'm going to share
a small anecdote when I got my PhD in
the 90s in the mid 90s
I graduated in in Germany and I did
something that is called pointless
whistling and I got a ten to fifteen
percent advantage out of my technique
and I was very very proud and then I
went to the US and the people said 10 to
15 percent that that doesn't matter
right it's if you if it's not an order
of magnitude or at least a factor of
three it doesn't matter
so now 20 years later I can tell you
that one percent actually matters one
percent in at the scale that we operate
is huge benefits in in any regard
yeah so one percent now matters and of
course now thinking back about my PhD
times well 10 15 percent yeah
right if I would do that today this is
great so just how how good the the times
are for us for people who optimized and
I'm an optimizer a person these these
things matter now and everything that we
are going to do is going to matter much
more and this is great now of course
this comes with expectations now when I
do an optimization then it needs to have
huge huge impact and and that's really
why we are here because we still kind of
have opportunities for orders of
magnitude but if they're not relevant if
they're not at the point where it really
matters then it is irrelevant 1% at the
right place matters a lot whereas an
order of magnitude somewhere in the
somewhere at an irrelevant place doesn't
matter and one of the things that we are
trying to achieve here together is kind
of finding the places where we can
really push forward and and make a huge
difference so Microsoft understands that
and one of the things that I want to
kind of say at the beginning I want to
kind of clear up with some of the myths
that maybe are in the community about
Microsoft Research so Microsoft really
understands this importance of finding
the right spot and how how how difficult
it is so I know that many of you and
care a lot about the silicon valley lab
and what happens in particular in
systems and I I'm just going to share my
personal thing and I think it was a
mistake and and I think that Microsoft
knows that it was a mistake and I think
Microsoft with this commitment that it
is making to Microsoft research and to
the scientific community is really
showing that it is that it is trying to
correct this mistake so this is what
Microsoft Research is and the I've
highlighted some of the important things
and that's where the myths are I want to
clarify is we are growing and this is a
we are growing we are hiring in in all
areas of core computer science and we
are growing not only in
in the people in research and in our
exposure our engagement so with what
sandy was mentioning how we engage with
you are we are growing but we are also
growing in our spread so our recent
member of the family is the montreal a
lab so we are also opening new labs and
and I think this is a this is important
and I would love you to kind of share
this and kind of internalize this and
share this in your communities and with
your students of course we are very
interested in in your students as part
of of this growth this is a slide that
I've shared from from Eric it's at the
top is the the Microsoft research
mission the advancing the
state-of-the-art and rapid which is what
we do with you where we engage with you
in the scientific community's rapidly
transfer this innovation into into
impact and just increasing the vibrancy
of the company and this mission has been
unchanged since 1991 the the bottom
layer is something that Eric actually
cares a lot about and keeps on saying
and this is our fabric our culture our
value system and this is creativity just
having ideas and we enjoy the ideas
collaboration working with you working
together within Microsoft Research
within Microsoft product groups but also
with you diversity and joy having fun
right and the the the important thing
also is of course also our competitors
they have understood that they that they
that they need to do research and create
research labs but this fabric is not
something that you build in five years
this takes a long long time and I think
this is what makes Microsoft research so
unique this is clearly I get asked a lot
why did you go to Microsoft research
from ETH which I still believe is a the
most wonderful place on the on the
planet being a professor
eh but the it's really this kind of
special culture and value system that
makes the difference
so of course Microsoft we also expects
us to generate value and there's a lot
of value kind of in working with the
business crew helping the business
creating new business one of the things
I've highlighted here is what we're
doing exactly here we are kind of the
ears and the eyes of the company and we
can engage with with you in a way that
product groups cannot do and this is a
very important part of Microsoft
research and Sandy's organization helps
everybody me as a researcher and my team
as research team to do exactly that
but the real kind of expectation of the
company is that we create surprises
that's really what Microsoft research is
about and and we have all these
dialogues and and the the what kind of
gives us the most pleasure is if we give
these talks to our executives and we see
the glowing eyes where they say oh yeah
yes we I hadn't thought about that and
of course this is again we can only
create surprises together with you
because this is creating some of these
surprises are putting many pieces of the
puzzle together and you are the people
who create many of these pieces and I'll
just going to give two tomorrow I'm
gonna give some examples of our kind of
today's surprises but I'll give two day
just for the introduction I'll give some
examples of historic surprises so one
surprise is is the Kinect which
hopefully all of you have heard about
which kind of God is original Microsoft
Research and it's a wonderful piece of
technology and I think it has it has
made many people are many children
definitely my children I have among the
four children I have three daughters and
they love the dancing games that only
works with Kinect oops
oh can can we go back please yeah sorry
yeah there because I have this red
button which I
I'm not allowed to press it it's always
dangerous to get something with a red
button in your hand I've read anyway so
so but now I'm not pressing it okay
anyway so that's the Kinect that's one
of the surprises I'm another one is
actually one where where Eric was
involved in is kind of from 1998 which
we would call the first smartphone and
this is another surprise and it yeah of
course we are very proud of being the
the source of that and it took 10 years
plus to make it really work and so this
is where I want to get at so all our
dreams have come come true that is that
is correct but that doesn't mean that we
don't have to work anymore and this is
kind of a chart we at we often think
about well we want to change the world
and we want to innovate and we often
hear this formula that innovation is
invention times impact and there is a
big mountain of innovation is what we as
researchers do all the time we we kind
of we do the science and we create new
ideas and we invent and then there's
another mountain which is creating
impact out of these ideas for creating
products and so on and these mountains
if you look at it at a time scale
somehow you have to have an idea before
you kind of at some point get to the
product but there's a big deep valley
between that and in this in the case of
the smartphone this valley was 10 years
it took 10 years before from the first
prototype of a smartphone out of the lab
of Microsoft research until nine years
until Apple kind of really got got
smartphones out and part of what we do
at Microsoft Research is to create this
stretch because we've realized that we
can no longer just kind of hope that
somehow our ideas will be picked up and
so we that is why we work very closely
with the product groups and I'm gonna
talk about that and in some sense for
you this is a great opportunity because
you kind of you're on the invention side
and you also kind of many of you have
startups and want to do that but some of
you maybe just want to be on the
invention side and you have through us
you have a vehicle to get your
inventions to impact and and this is
this is this is a kind of an opportunity
that we would love you to use of course
also in our own interest but also in
your interest and in the interest of
making the world a better place and and
for us of course it is a it is a big
challenge because we love the science
part but we also love the kind of the
kind of building stuff and and bringing
it out part and and doing this stretch
is kind of often that's kind of in my
everyday work for people who are kind of
too much in love with the science
pushing them to to go to the impact is a
is one thing that I have to do but also
for some people who are just about
impact pushing them back into the sides
is also one thing that I do so here's a
just a little bit how we work with
product groups because we work very
closely with the product groups but
there are there there we play a special
role and this is what I was trying to to
visualize with this stretch we do a lot
of things that the product groups cannot
do right we have a long term perspective
we sometimes have a disruptive idea
perspective we our funding is completely
independent of product groups yeah so
this hasn't changed and this is we are
we have our funding and we are not
obliged to work with product groups
nobody is and we have their more product
roots that we can even serve and we are
we choose what we do but when we do
choose to work with product groups we we
take different perspectives we take
risks we are more agile and that is we
are about taking risks and of course we
collaborate with you which is in and we
collaborate with our competitors we have
very open discussions and
with and work with Google and Facebook
and all of these researchers and
engineers in those organizations I also
want to comment a little bit of our
relationship with on our relationship
with you there are two forms where we
where we interact one is in the
scientific communities and I think we
are partners equal right partners we
write papers together and I hope we will
continue to do that we serve on program
committees together we do all the
service work together and and I think
academics and Microsoft Research
researchers are interchangeable in the
scientific communities I think most of
you don't even care in the scientific
community whether you are now talking to
Microsoft Research person the other
interest in more interesting
relationship is the is the talent side
of course we heavily depend on on you
because you are kind of the source of
all ultimately if the of all talent but
we also help you with our internship
program and we want to really intensify
that and this is a huge part of what we
do and now it's summer and your interns
are in building 99 here and we are
having a great great time and but I
think we're also helping you where with
with this with this program and the the
little bit more subtle thing is we also
compete with you you are looking for
recruiting you junior faculty we are
looking for recruiting so that's a
little bit of a healthy I think aspect
of of our relationship but what you
shouldn't forget is that you also that
we also create and grow talent that you
will hire later so there is there are
many career trajectories where students
go to Microsoft Research and get this
final booth to then go back to academia
and do really outstanding research in
academia so with that I want to kind of
come to the systems part and also
introduce our first keynote speaker
so kind of you've all know seen some of
pictures like that where there's I mean
today there's computing everywhere we
have this public cloud we have private
clouds and we have all of these devices
and an our CEO Satya Nadella he often
talks about the intelligent edge and the
intelligent cloud and so the intelligent
cloud is of course the public cloud and
maybe some parts of the private cloud
and the edge are all of these gazillions
of devices that go around and form one
big system and as we are a company also
and now I want to introduce our first
keynote speaker who essentially is the
mastermind of Azure and Azure is kind of
the the way we kind of draw boxes around
of these things so Azure is of course
our public cloud but a joke Azure stack
is also our private cloud and the two
together form the the the the hybrid
cloud and asher is also our iot or edge
story with the smaller devices and so
the mastermind behind that is mark
russinovich who is the CTO of
asia he he got his PhD from Carnegie
Mellon University and since then has had
a very fruitful career with many many
activities so he's really passionate
about distributed systems about security
about operating systems his he's been
working on Windows and Asia obviously
for a long time and he has created many
tools so he is the he's the author of
the SIS integration administration tools
for Windows he is the he had several
stints among others at IBM but in 1996
he he started a company called winter
nuts which was eventually acquired by
Microsoft in 2006 and since 2006 he has
been with Microsoft and
has created essentially help create a
sure and and and holding Asha together
one of the very interesting facts about
Mark is that he's a very passionate
speaker but also a very passionate
author and he wrote books not only
technical books but also fictional books
and fictional kind of technical
fictional books and and I haven't read
them but I've now I have two three books
but I've actually looked in it's a and
I'm gonna read one of them and you could
you can look them up so with that please
welcome mark russinovich thank you very
much
[Applause]
you